las protestas se han prolongado durante
días con las clases de agua y los cortes
de energía eléctrica la organización de
derechos humanos que proporcionó este
vídeo muestra a la policía
antidisturbios disparando contra
manifestantes en una ciudad al suroeste
del país en la región rica en petróleo
de cuestan varias personas han muerto en
las protestas y las autoridades culpan a
los agitadores
debemos estar enfocados en proteger los
derechos de la comunidad local para
protestar pacíficamente y tener este
espacio sin temor para hacer escuchar
sus demandas por parte de las
autoridades locales y nacionales anda jr
y usted el patrón de abuso que se viene
dando desde hace décadas contra los
manifestantes nos preocupa mucho sobre
como el gobierno podría escalar the
government
irán ha sufrido sequías durante décadas
pero esta es particularmente grave las
precipitaciones han disminuido un 60% de
marzo a mayo en comparación con el año
anterior y las sequías siguen empeorando
debido al cambio climático
los expertos culpan a la estrategia de
irán de desviar el agua de las áreas de
minorías étnicas a partes centrales del
país dejando a millones de iraníes
sufriendo escasez durante largos
períodos a mediados del verano
el experto en agua el profesor cada vez
madani fue contratado para revisar la
gestión ambiental de irán en 2017 y
culpa de los problemas actuales al
fracaso de irán en la reforma del cuando
construyes muchos depósitos esperas
tener el peñón para regular el agua
conservarla y almacenarla pero esto no
sucedió porque irán no planifico bien la
creación de sumar avisos y demanda de
agua
words mientras tanto en otras partes del
país hubo fuertes inundaciones que según
los críticos también podrían haberse
evitado con una gestión adecuada